welcome to another famous Friday I
believe that whatever goal you have
whatever challenges in front of you
somebody has already solved it and the
best way to accomplish your goal is to
model the success of people who've
already reached those goals before you
so today we're gonna learn from Tom
Monaghan the founder of Domino's Pizza
and his lesson is commit now when Tom
Monaghan was growing up he had a lot of
commitment issues when he was 4 years
old his father died on Christmas Eve and
his mother felt like she couldn't
support him she couldn't have kids she
couldn't handle the stress and all the
work involved so she gave him up for
adoption and he bounced from orphanage
to orphanage to foster home to foster
home never was able to really commit to
a family nobody committed back to him
when he was in high school his freshman
year he couldn't commit to high school
and he said you know what I don't think
this is for me I'm gonna go become a
priest and so we joined the seminary
school but he couldn't commit to that
either and he got expelled after a year
so went back to high school and he
finished and they got his degree but he
didn't really commit to it he that there
were 44 people in his graduating class
and he finished 44th of everybody on his
yearbook under his picture he wrote
there harder I try to be good the worst
I get but I may do something sensational
yet I love that because it's got a
little believed in at that right even
though he's sucked and failed and
couldn't commit to anything yet he still
believed that something sensational is
about to happen so he graduated from
school and he thought about going to
university instead he didn't commit to
that he joined the Marine Corps and he
saved up a little bit of money to start
a business and he bought this business
off the snake oil salesman that that
went under it was the guy just basically
stole his money and he ended up being
broke having $15 to his name being in
San Diego and having to hitchhike dock
to his home in Ann Arbor Michigan that's
where things started to change for him
he went back home he met his brother and
he decided to get into the pizza
business right just another thing the
truck is that's that's been the story of
his life bouncing one thing to another
thing to another thing to another thing
and never fully committing so they
started pizza business they borrowed
$900 together they buy a failing pizza
business and they decide to take it over
and for the first time in his life Tom
Monaghan really applies himself he's
working 100-hour weeks to get this
business off the ground he's killing
himself he's committing he's really
putting everything he's got into this
business but it's not taking off and you
know you know as an entrepreneur when
you're starting up a company you're full
of excitement you're full of energy
you're so pumped for how great
everything's gonna be and then the wall
hits you right when you realize it's
gonna be way harder than you thought it
was gonna be and six months in working
1800 hour weeks his brother tells him I
can't do this anymore
this is way too much work we're not
making enough money I'm gonna I'm gonna
move on I'm gonna do something else and
this was the turning point in Tom wanna
ins life because it would have been so
easy for him to say yeah you know what
you're right I'm gonna do something else
too this isn't working and just bounced
another thing because that's all he did
his whole life is bounced to another
thing instead Tom Monaghan for the first
time decided that he was going to really
commit himself to something and he gave
up the only thing the only thing he had
a value the only asset he had was his
Volkswagen Beetle and he traded his only
asset that car to his brother in
exchange for this brothers shares in the
business so he would own 100% of the
company and in doing that he said I made
the decision to commit myself heart and
soul to being a pizza man my purpose was
clear and the knowledge that the future
success or failure of the business
rested on my shoulders alone was welcome
so finally he committed himself to
something and that's when the business
started to take off he turned his 1
location around he started franchising
opening up more locations and eventually
built a brand name that people know that
is across the
he had every excuse in the world not to
do it right you think as entrepreneurs
we come with all of excuses not to take
action and he had a lot of them right oh
I didn't have a family that supports me
I didn't have a father figure in my life
I bounced around from from family to
family orphanage to orphanage I didn't
really get a great education I was a
last in my class in high school I never
went to university I didn't have a lot
of money
I put whatever money I had into a
business and didn't work out right all
the excuses in the world not to be
successful as an entrepreneur and yet he
plowed through am i committing himself
built an empire so look at yourself in
the mirror look at the excuses you're
telling yourself for not taking action
for not getting started you're not
really fully committing yourself to your
business and you can decide to take that
step then you too could be on your path
to building your empire believe you guys
like this video you want to see more
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much for watching I'll see you soon
don't forget to click here to subscribe
to my newsletter to get actionable
inspiring motivational believe advice
every single week to your inbox hi I'm
Jason Grif on sigur rós online.com and I
want to say Evan Carmichael's newsletter
is consistent fun inspiring and it's
only newsletter I prioritize and look
forward to period